après le succès de la première édition
les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veulent
transformer l'essai le mois de la bande
dessinée devenir le festival bubble sky
et l'agglomération adopte la culture
japonaise du manga sur la durée du
festival
il y à des expositions des ateliers de
dessin dans les médiathèques vous pouvez
retrouvez la programmation sur le site
internet des médiathèques
on reçoit aussi des portraitistes manga
qui peut venir vous croquez façon manga
dans plusieurs médiathèque de saint
quentin et la programmation riche des
cinémas entre manga film japonais les
cinémas d'indépendance se sont donc
ajoutés aux festivités en criant même
l'exploit le grenier à sel est l'un des
rares cinéma français a diffusé le
célèbre manga akira le 24 février pour
jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout la
médiathèque du canal a transformé son
auditorium en manga qui ça ces salons de
thé japonais conçu pour y lire ce manga
tranquillement mais avant de profiter de
la vue sur le canal enneigées petit tour
par l'exposition
on a aussi la chance de travailler avec
le conservatoire des arts de
montigny-le-bretonneux est donc cette
année le professeur de bande dessinée
monsieur jean pierre a fait travailler
ses élèves autour du manga à notre
sollicitation
voilà et donc du coup et on a une très
jolie exposition sous forme de stickers
de deux planches que compte travailler
ses élèves donc de 6 à 77 ans le
festival buzz sky se tiendra jusqu'au 4
mars dont toutes les médiathèques et les
cinémas indépendants de l'agglomération